[Music]
Con Academy proudly presents a tale of
two credit scores this is Jana hi and
this is Bob good morning narrator hi Bob
these two Charming characters are
co-workers each with the same job and
salary they both need a vehicle so
they've traveled to this used car
dealership together so they can each buy
a new ride I'm all about this model it's
got everything I need it's got the
all-wheel drive it's got the Adaptive
braking it's got the backup camera and
it's it's a hatchback going to carry so
much Furniture in this thing they are
greeted by Susanna an employee at the
dealership Jana Bob I got your message
oh good these hatchbacks have been
flying off the lot but I'd reserved one
for each of you you're both sure this is
what you want definitely we both did a
lot of research yeah we're both sure but
I've got a question understandably
what's the damage how much is this car
going to cost we have this car listed at
$13,750 after taxes and fees we're
looking at
$15,500 out the door are you paying cash
or you both thinking about financing
financing okay follow me inside we've
got some applications to fill out will
there be oversized novelty pins oh yeah
and so Jana and Bob got out their
writing implements and entered the
enchanting world of paperwork they gave
permission to the dealership to run
credit reports on each of them they
answered a barrage of questions about
their finances finally Jana and Bob got
their applications back from the
dealership okay so I've got some good
news and I've got great news great news
first yeah great news Jana we got you
approved for a 36-month term with a
monthly payment of
$453 all right I can afford that for
sure good news Bob you are also approved
for the exact same 36-month term and a
monthly payment of
$584 wait let me do some math before I
agree with you about it being good news
it's good news you are approved no help
me out Jana your loan comes to a total
of $
16,38 and yours
$584 time
36 let's see that's
$2,024 how am I paying almost $5 ,000
more than you it's the same car is that
legal great question pause what do you
think is happening here is this even a
question of course it's not legal Bob
I'm talking to the Learners we'll get
back to you in a minute so it is legal I
said pause Bob he said pause come on
sorry where was I what do you think is
happening share your perspective with
your classmates or write them down pause
the video here and then enjoy 5 Seconds
of peaceful jazz
music
[Music]
so what accounts for the vast difference
between Bob's loan offer and Jana's loan
offer it all comes down to the credit
score let's dig into that the dealership
asked a credit bureau to evaluate how
risky it would be to loan money to Jana
or Bob their credit scores are an
illustration of that risk Jana's credit
score is 800 which is excellent great
job Jana thank you that score means that
Jana is a lowrisk borrower low-risk
borrowers get low interest rates she
pays her bills on time she uses her
credit
responsibly Bob on the other hand uhoh
Bob has a credit score of 500 to be
blunt this is a pretty bad credit score
Bob's credit report shows that he's
consistently late paying his bills he's
outright missed a bunch of payments and
here it says he defaulted on a loan in
the past that's a huge red flag for
lender but why is it more expensive for
me than it is for Jana so given your
credit history they think it's likelier
that you won't pay them for the full
amount of the car to make up for that
risk your loan carries a 21% interest
rate which means you're paying thousands
of dollars more in interest over the
life of the loan 5,000 to be exact and
again that's legal afraid so this sucks
did you know credit scores were such a
big deal I knew a little yeah I Knew Too
of course you did after signing their
contract Bob and Jana regroup at a
coffee shop Jana to celebrate Bob to
drown his sorrows in coffee
another I think you've had enough pal
I'll stop when I'm good and
ready how did everything get so
expensive that's part of the problem
Robert you didn't know when to stop you
maxed out your credit cards I'm a free
spirit you defaulted on that business
loan 5 years ago the market was not
ready for chocolate covered beef jerky
and it still isn't Bobby and you ignored
your credit report whereas Jana paid her
bills on time thank you she kept her
credit card balances low mhm and she
kept an eye on her credit score they ran
a credit check on me before I moved and
my credit score helped me to rent my new
place the score is a reflection of the
choices I've
made so Jana how can I be more like you
can credit scores change they absolutely
can okay how I assume there's not some
magic wand there isn't but there are a
lot of steps you can take you can enroll
in a financial literacy course like this
one exactly you can monitor your credit
with websites and apps like Credit Karma
and if you see something weird you can
dispute errors like one time my credit
report showed a boat loan you don't have
a boat I never had a boat but it dinged
my credit and I successfully disputed
that I said that's not me and they
verified it so there's that but you'll
also need to work on your debt I can get
you the name of a credit counselor if
you want I'd appreciate that very much J
yeah on second thought I might want
another coffee can I get you anything
that's very kind Jan but I can't be
opening up a new line of credit right
now you goober it's on me come on and so
we leave our two friends to untangle the
Twisted bonds of credit to demystify the
conundrum of risk to master their money
and improve their lives remember that
your credit score is one of the keys to
your financial happiness but a bad score
is not Destiny you have the power to
change it use credit responsibly pay off
your bills and if needed seek credit
counseling this has been the tale of two
credit scores thank you and good
[Music]
night